اشتريت كميه من الكوفيه الفلسطينيه اشتريت
كميه من الاساور الي بتدل على العالم
الفلسطيني والخريطه الفلسطينيه حضرت نفسي
ذهنيا ونفسيا اني اول هدف الي انشر قضيتي
انشر قضيه فلسطين اوصل صوت الى العالم كله
صوت فلسطين للعالم كله والعالم العربي
بالتحديد
[موسيقى]
مرحبا يعطيكم العافيه بحكي معكم قيس عبد
الله نصر من فلسطين سكان مدينه نابلس
للتحديد عمري 24 سنه خريج الجامعه العربيه
الامريكيه في جنين نسيت على قطر هون عشان
اقدم مبادره جميله وحلوه وفكره كثير ناس
حبتها اللي هي حضور فلسطين في المونديال
او اللي هي فكره هاشتاج كان اسمه فلسطين
في المونديال كيف هذه الفكره كانت الفكره
عباره عن تقديم الاساور وحطيت فلسطين او
الكوفيه الفلسطينيه للناس بشكل عام
[موسيقى]
وكانت الرساله محتواها واضح وصريح الفكره
للعالم كله انه فلسطين متواجده في كل زمان
ومكان قضيه فلسطين والشعب الفلسطيني حاضر
حتى في المونديال 22
فلسطين مشاركه المونديال دائما كيف مشاركه
في المونديال راح احكيلك قديش حب الناس
لها قديش يحب العرب قديش حب الناس للقضيه
قديش الناس دعمك
[موسيقى]
اكيد اخترت التوقيت المونديال لانه اكبر
تجمع للناس على مستوى العالم يعني كل
الناس بتجمعوا من كافه الاماكن عشان
يحضروا هذا المونديال فما بالك فلسطين
تكون موجوده في هذا المونديال
[موسيقى]
نهايه فكره المبادره كانت انه نوصل هاي
الاساور وهاي الكوفيه الاكبر عدد ممكن من
الناس عشان يعرف قضيتنا ويعرف الوطن
الفلسطيني وما ينفقضيه هذه
[موسيقى]
كاس العالم بين كل شيء بما اني لاعب كره
قدم حالي انا لاعب في نادي اتحاد نابلس
الدوري الفلسطيني طبعا لي تقريبا 17 سنه
يلعب كره قدم اكيد
حلم كاس العالم وحضور كاس العالم حلم اي
لاعب كره قدم
وبما اني مشجع كره قدم اكيد طبعا اكيد
احنا مشجع المنتخبات العربيه اولا الصف
الاول ثم نشجع البرتغال بعد المنتخبات
العربيه اللاعب المفضل اكيد كريستيانو
رونالدو كلمه من كل قلبي الى جمهورنا
العربي في المونديال بالذات اول شكرا لكم
على دعم قضيتنا الفلسطيني بهذه الطريقه
الشعب الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]
فلسطين هي هويتي هي وطني هي دمي هي كل ما
املك في حياتي فعلا فلسطين هي موجوده في
الحدث هي فقلب الحدث كل المنتخبات العربيه
تونس والمغرب سعوديه وقطر وايضا ما ننسى
قضيتنا لقضيه راح تبقى الى ان تتحرر
فلسطين وهي قضيه نفلت فلسطين والقدس تبقى
هي عاصمه فلسطين
العرب كلها الاعلام الفلسطينيه موجوده بكل
الملاعب وهذا شيء كثير احنا بنتشرف فيك
كثير مبسوطين انه موجود بكل الملاعب وبكل
الاحتفالات وحتى حوالين الملاعب موجود من
كل الدول العالميه ومش بس من الدول
العربيه
[موسيقى]
فلسطين فلسطين
لا كلمه ولا كلمات نقدر نوصف حبها في
قلوبنا بعد الحكي طبعا بلسانه الشعب
الفلسطيني
[موسيقى]